Hello,
and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy. I
am your host, David Flanagan, and today is
another episode of Rawkode live. A show where
we take a look at cloud native software
to help assist you make your Kubernetes cloud
native microservices lives a little bit easier.
Today, we have a follow-up episode as we
take a look at Robusta,
and specifically,
we're gonna take a look at how Robusta
can improve or enhance our monitoring of Kubernetes
clusters with Previous.
I'm joining us today. Excuse me. I am
sitting in the freezing cold. It's minus five
and the heating is broken in my building.
I'm just gonna get that out there in
case I start shivering.
Joining us today
are two wonderful guests that we've had before,
Nathan and Eric. Hey. How's it going?
It's going good. Thank you for having us
back here.
I tried so hard not to mention that
it was freezing cold, but I could already
feel my teeth chittering as I talk. So
I just Yeah.
Like I said before this thing, the things
that you do for the Internet.
I mean
Guys, if you haven't hit that subscribe button.
Yeah. I'll I'll just I'll let you do
all the talking today. I appreciate it.
Alright.
For anyone who hasn't seen our last episode
or isn't familiar with you both on LinkedIn
and Twitter, etcetera, can you both tell us
a little bit about you and what you've
been up to?
Yeah. So what we do is we do
runbook automation for Kubernetes based Prometheus. And that's
a mouthful, so I'm gonna break that down
with an analogy.
So I wanna start with a nontechnical
example that I'll use to explain what this
says and why it matters. So let me
share my screen.
And I'm gonna start off with my favorite
website on the Internet, me, of course, Reddit.
And what I have up on here
is a subreddit called, why is this thing?
And this is a subreddit where you can
go and
people go on here and they post pictures
of different things, and they say, why is
this thing? So, like, someone here posted a
picture of this blue disc that they found
in the bag of crisps. I think crisps
is British for some kind of snack, but
Yeah. It's it's British for chips.
Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Exactly.
And they said, why is this thing? And
then people go in the comments, they try
and guess what something is. And this is
a metaphor for something related to Kubernetes,
but I'll get there in just a moment.
So
I wanna take an example that someone posted
a few years ago. This is the number
three post of all time. And someone posted
on here,
I found this box in the attic,
and, you know, what is this thing? And
you look at the box, and it says
on here, this is radioactive material,
route one or two, whatever that means. No
person shall remain within one meter of this
container unnecessarily.
And, of course, it's, I guess, in The
US, so they translate that to three feet.
If
you didn't figure out, you should get the
hell away from this.
And
radioactive
units of this thing and so on and
so on. And they posted this on Reddit,
and everyone on Reddit said, why are you
posting this on Reddit? Department
of Energy.
The Department of Energy came up to their
house, and that's like the guys with the
spacesuits. So they have on the spacesuits, and
they have that thing that goes beep, the
Geiger counter, and they're going all over the
place.
And the person is certain that he's gonna
die, and he's gonna be in the hospital,
or he got, like, a special iodine or
whatever.
And after this whole big thing and all
this excitement,
it turned out that it was all a
false alarm and
that this box just just had some old
Raidon paint
and
Iridium paint. And for people who aren't familiar
with it, then they used to paint watches
so they would glow in the dark with
this radioactive paint. And it wasn't good, and
a lot of people got cancer because they
worked in the factories and they would lick
it. So you shouldn't go around licking this
paint, but, like, if you find in your
attic, you're not gonna die. Everything is fine.
Nothing happens.
And
now I don't know. I am do you
do you wanna guess where I'm going with
this?
I'm still wondering what the little blue disc
was. But
Oh, the the old blue disc is in
but it's too far off topic. So I
recommend afterwards.
Me.
Yeah. I'm pretty sure we're spend the next
three hours after the stream on this subreddit,
just looking through all the most random stuff.
But I'll let you get back onto your
your point.
I'm embarrassed to admit how many of these
things here are purple.
So, me yeah. So going back to this
though, the point here is that this is
really representative of something that happens to us
all the time in the world of SRE
and DevOps and when we're operating stuff in
production. What happens all the time is you
get some of their in your Slack channel,
and it could potentially be really bad. And
you wanna understand as fast as possible,
is this an alert that is going to
take down my production? Is this something I
need to look at right now? Or if
it's 3AM, can I go back to sleep
and just deal with this in the morning?
And now when you get to bigger companies,
then it's also a matter of responsibility. So
just like you yourself didn't know by looking
at this box whether, like, it was a
big deal or not, you had to call
that team with the Geiger counters
and with the spacesuits. In a big company,
you're not always the person who is not
even has the context or the knowledge to
look at and alert and understand what to
do with it. So what we're trying to
do with Robusta is when you see a
radioactive box like this, we're trying to say,
you know, this box isn't so bad. Like,
okay, you'll call up someone you're disposed of
in a safe manner, but, like, it's okay.
You can go back to work and relax.
Or we're trying to say, you know, this
box is actually really bad. Get over your
house right now. And that's what we call
runbook automation.
And in the Kubernetes context now, if I
jump over to, like, a concrete example, then
we're taking Prometheus alerts, like this Prometheus alert
that said pause is crash looping, and we're
trying to get you as fast as possible
to understand what does this alert mean? Does
it mean something? Should I stop everything I'm
doing and have people investigate what's going on
in production right now? Or is this something
like that radioactive box that isn't such a
big deal and can wait?
Okay. I get it now. I understand the
Reddit hook.
So I have to say, I'm
gonna stop thinking about it. And I'm sure
there are other people there who won't stop
thinking about it until we say. So that
blue thing, the blue chip in the bag,
they put the they do quality control and
they, like, run some blue chip that's, that's
metallic through. And then they're supposed to identify
all the blue chips and take them out
of the process. And if a blue chip
escapes the process and gets to the end,
like something was faulty with the equipment. So
the blue chip shouldn't have been there. When
the blue chip goes missing, they know when
the machines are, like, the production lines has
broken down.
Uh-huh.
There we go. Today, I learned.
Now we can stop thinking about that. Okay.
Yeah. So David, you've heard a little bit
about Robusta before. You've seen it a little
bit. So does this make does it make
sense?
Yeah. It does make sense.
Yeah. I think there's you know, one of
the things I think is really important when
it comes to operating Kubernetes,
you know, something that I I do quite
a lot is trying to
improve the signal to noise ratio,
specifically with monitoring as that is very easy
for you to get alert fatigue for things
to be alert and all the time
because you know what, Kubernetes is eventually consistent,
nodes go away, this go away, everything is
completely ephemeral to a certain degree and that
reconciliation process will cause alerts depending on how
you have them tweaked.
And then
something I'm guilty of, I guess, is well,
sometimes I just change the parameters of those
alerts so that I'm actually not notified as
quickly as I should be,
but I'm trying to reduce that noise and
just get more of the signals.
And that's a wrong approach to do it
and I'm really hoping that what you're going
to show us today is actually going to
give me ways for me to improve that
just so that
I get more sleep most of the time
I guess would be really nice. If you
get me more sleep, I'll be a happy
man.
And I still have the original Robusta t
shirt. I don't know if you're still giving
them away the cube control get sleep but
that thing is great. Yeah. I like like
my sleep.
You got a UI, yes, because I'm so
lucky in a little bit but we still
have some You're one of the lucky people
with originals.
Right.
Yeah.
So to test to to just touch on
that and to really, like, about about what
you said, then, yeah, it's absolutely a goal.
There's, two challenges. One is always a good
set of default alerts. So we're doing some
work there, and we're taking existing alerts and
trying to put it together into a good
collection and to really add on context to,
like, what does this alert mean?
And then the other part of what we're
doing is to really, like, when an alert
fires, all the data is there.
The problem isn't that the signal isn't there.
The problem is that the signal is buried
in data. So you don't really need, like,
another monitoring system. You don't need more metrics.
You don't need more alerts. Like, all the
data is there. You don't need more dogs.
You have all the dogs. You just need
to see the right data at the right
time. So part of, like, one way you
could describe what we're doing is we're doing
monitoring
orchestration.
So we're orchestrating, like, all your existing monitoring,
but putting it together and tying it together
in a coherent picture.
Alright. Awesome.
Yeah. So I'll just say two quick words
about the architecture.
And then from there, I think we'll just
jump into a live demo.
And at the end, maybe we'll jump back
over here, and I can speak a little
bit about what's new since last time for
people who have seen this before, and what
we're going to be doing in the next
year. So just to get started, so a
quick reminder,
when you're using Prometheus, then typically you have
a setup where you have Prometheus that generates
alerts,
and that sends them to their manager.
And the alert manager has some extra functionality,
like grouping the alerts together and waiting a
certain amount of time before it forwards them.
And then it sends that by webhook to
destination like Slack or like MS Teams.
And this is the normal setup. And then
you get in Slack, you get alerts like
this, which are great, and they sometimes indicate
real problems, but they don't have context.
So here you can see an example. Here
you have a crashing pod, but it doesn't
have context on why the pod is crashing.
And
I like to say when all you have
is a time series database and everything looks
like a time series.
So
time series databases are excellent at using them
to write rules, identify when problems occur. They're
not good at telling you why those issues
occurred, though. So what we're doing with Robusta
is we're adding on an additional component. We're
leaving the first half of this exactly the
same. So, you that comes from Prometheus to
alert manager.
And then instead of going directly to stack,
it gets sent to Robusta.
And Robusta now has rules that go in
to gather data about why that are fired
and what's the context. This is an observability
engine here or runbook engine if you prefer
that knows how to take that error and
correlate it with those Kubernetes objects. So there
was an inert on the pod. Go to
that pod, look at it, pull in the
dogs. There was a pod that was pending.
Go pull in the output of kubectl get
events. Show me the reason why it's pending.
And we have rules here in this observability
engine, so we can go and we can
gather all the data, and then we just
forward it on to destinations like stock.
Okay.
So the runbook engine sets
it receives all the alert manager alerts, and
then you have some sort of utility. It
just goes collect logs and other data and
then forwards them on to my so the
Slack or whatever I wanna send those alerts
to. So you're just kind of retching that
alert with the information that people need to
actually understand if it is signal or noise
and what they have to do about it.
Right?
Exactly.
And the in data and the enrichments here,
they could be really simple or really complex.
It's like a simple enrichment as a pod
is crashing, just fetch the dog for me.
So now in stock, I get the other
with that pod's dog. And I'm thinking about,
like, how a big company works. Like, now
the developer
you can route that directly to the developer.
And even if the developer doesn't know that
much about Kubernetes,
he can immediately see the dog there, and
then you can triage it and decide whether
it's a development issue that the developer should
look at or if it's an infra issue
that someone from the infrastructure team should look
at. So there's simple stuff like dogs, and
then there's more complex stuff like, a pilot
with CPU throttle, go and look at the
memory limits, and look at sorry. Go and
look at CPU limits, the CPU requests, perform
some actual
complicated analysis on that and tell me why
it happens. So sometimes we're just pulling in
right the right data, and sometimes we're taking,
a a known alert and we're going really
deep on that and tell me why it
happens.
Is this static or dynamic? And, like, I
mean, by that, like, have you already defined
what the collection sources are when an alert
manager alert triggers, or is this something that
I enrich with my own logic and code?
Could I call some arbitrary API? Like, what
does this runbook engine
look like from my point of view? Oh,
excellent question. So what it looks like
if you wanna go and you wanna define
stuff yourself, then it looks like just a
YAML definition. So you have here a YAML
file that says,
when there's this Prometheus alert for QPod crash
looping, go and reach that with the dogs.
But most people need to do that. So
you can go and you can add on
your own rules,
and a big part of our focus in
2023 is gonna make this even easier and
to add on better documentation
and to make it super easy to do
and to add on your own rules.
But out of the box, we define a
base set of alerts.
If you use Kube Prometheus stack, we define
base set of enrichments for Kube Prometheus stack.
And out of the box, we try and
give you something that will work for most
people that you won't need to fine tune,
you won't need to customize at all.
Alright. Cool.
And then the last thing I'll say, and
then we'll jump right over already to a
live demo,
is we take in more data, not just
from alert manager. Since the last time that
you talk, that we talked, I think, we
took over Kube Watch as the official maintainers,
and we'll be announcing very soon Kube Watch
version two. So this is a utility that
was once by before
it was before
they stopped maintaining it, that tracks all the
different Kubernetes changes by listening to the API
server.
So we take in data from, Kube Watch
so we can see, like, when an ingress
changes, and we can see when, pods change,
and we can see when jobs fail, we
can get all this data. And we take
in data from other sources, like from an
Elasticsearch, we you can send data. We can
take in data from all these sources, not
just the Dirt Manager, and then tie them
all together into coherent picture.
But we're mostly gonna focus on this today
on the others.
Alright. Awesome.
Well, I'm excited to play with it. Are
we moving over to my screen now?
We are. That's it. I'm done talking.
That
means I have to take my hands out
of my pocket, but we'll do it. So
I'm sorry.
I have a terminal
with a Kubernetes cluster running on JKE.
I have two tabs here. One with some
demos that you've sent me. So if anyone
else wants to check these out in their
own time, you can go to github.com/robusta-dev
and that is Kubernetes
dash demos.
The other one we've got is just your
Robusta.
So if you're completely new to Robusta and
wanna check it out and go to the
Robusta repository
or the docs. I guess both would work.
So
am I
Oh, we should I should send you to
the docs. Well, I was gonna say like,
am I just gonna go to the docs
and deploy Robusta to this cluster?
Is it covered in the readme's for the
demos?
What's what's what's step one?
Okay. Yeah. So I sent you a a
demo re I sent you a demo repository
in advance,
but you should start at, like, the normal
Robusta repository.
Yep. Or just click the big get starting
button for the docs. Yeah. Let's just go
straight to that installation. Alright? So
alright.
Zoom. Zoom. Zoom.
Okay. So we're going to be installing with
Helm.
Do we need to robust the CLI?
We do. Alright.
Do I have pip?
Oh, I think I do. I think it's
pip three. There we go.
There's another option there that you can just
use Docker container if you don't have pip.
Yeah. I I don't run Docker desktop that
often.
I actually don't have access to containers really.
Everything's in Kubernetes now. Right?
Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
Then we're going to do a robust dot
gen config. Oh, there's a nice copy button.
Might as well use that.
And let's see what this spits out.
Okay. Do I want to configure a Slack
integration? Do we need that for today or
will I say no?
I think it would be best if there's
a Slack we can add it to. I
think it would be best.
Alright.
Connect Robusta to Slack. Sure.
Nope.
Too many Slack channels.
That's why wrong profile.
Is that it?
Yep. Yep. That's it. That was a bit
too easy.
Try. We do our best.
But there's always issues. There's always issues in
every live demo. So
No. I'm definitely saying no to that one.
What is the Robusta UI sync?
So that's our SaaS platform. I would recommend
enabling that for the demo.
Me.
So do I need to sign up to
Robusta SaaS?
Yeah. You just put in here. Just put
in an email. You don't need us so
you don't need us set up anywhere else.
Just put in a new email. Yeah. That's
it. It'll generate it for you.
Alright.
So Robusta can use Prometheus as an alert
source.
You can
install a preconfigured Prometheus. Yes, please.
Sure.
Okay. So this has generated
helm values file.
Oh, bunch of keys in there.
Yep.
Okay.
I'll just show everybody them. That's not important.
Right?
No. It's fine.
Alright. So let's add the rebuster repository
and run a helm update.
And then we do an install.
And I'll need to change.
Do I have a small cluster?
No. I don't think so. Alright.
I guess this might just take a wee
minute.
Yeah. No worries.
So what time is it where you're at?
It's 07:30 over here.
You?
05:30.
Yeah.
Yep.
Is it cold where you are?
Oh, it's all the matter. It's active. I
I can't say yes.
It still made us five. Okay.
Okay. It looks like we're installed.
It looks like I can go to platformrobusta.dev
for some sort of web UI.
And I'm assuming if I run
get pods, we'll see some Robusta stuff happening.
There. There we go.
Cool.
Alright. What do you want me to do
next?
Let's go back to the docs.
And
let's just wait, I guess, until the pods
are up and running.
Yeah. So that's just the command there.
And then we're gonna crash some stuff. Let's
break some stuff in your cluster.
That I can handle.
And
that's some fun. You should have also gotten
a message on Slack, I believe. It sends
a message just to confirm the Slack channel.
So
we're gonna wanna bring up Slack too.
Alright.
So
we have all the pods
and then you want me to deploy this
thing to break stuff?
Yeah. That's deploy crashing pods.
Alright. We have a crash in pods.
So does this mean I'm gonna see something
in my Slack channel?
You should. Yeah.
I don't know why that keeps deselecting.
You have to wait them we don't send
it on the first crash because, this is
exactly the type of thing that you spoke
about. Right? Like, you have these transient issues
with Kubernetes,
and you don't wanna alert as soon as
something happens that, like, that second, it's gonna
then disappear. So we try and always find
the right balance. What's the point where this
is really an issue that you then want
to get notified, not just a transient issue.
Okay. So we have a
high severity
crashing pod. We have an investigate button.
It's telling us it's crashed twice. It's gonna
crash it back off and it's collected some
logs from the
application. Quite a lot of logs from the
application.
I can't believe you put Java in my
cluster. You know I have rules about that.
Right?
I actually
if you wanna okay. Take a look at
what that is.
Take a look at take a look at
the pod that's running.
Computer.
I'm not a monster. I only put Java
in there. Oh, it's BusyBox. Right. Okay.
It's a BusyBox command that outputs. Well, according
to Google, it was the world's dark longest
Java exception.
Well, yes. Slack warning told me, do I
want to expand this thousand line
log message.
It is experience.
Oh,
yeah. That's the truncated to a 68 lines.
Alright. We have a crashing pod. We got
a nice alert.
What's next?
Okay. So let's
go and let's go over now to the
demo scenarios repository that I sent you, and
let's deploy some more stuff from over there.
Cool.
So that demo one was just to show
the Slack integration that's posting something to my
my channel.
Yep. And now we'll show an example of
a different error that occurs where we pull
in different data.
So Okay. So these demos then are demos
that you're going to show off the enrichment
process that you covered on the slides and
how that gives us more context than to
what's actually crashing. Right?
Yeah. Exactly. And we've tried to pick the
demo scenarios so they don't actually mess up
your cluster. Like, I love to show how,
for example, we have an issue with those
disk space,
and then we pull in,
like, a graph of the disk usage on
that node. But if I do that, that's
gonna actually mess up one of your nodes.
Now in your case, that's okay, But we
try demo scenarios that won't really mess up
a cluster.
So,
I mean, it's mostly stuff that there's an
issue with this specific part.
Oh, yeah. This is just a
cluster for today. So if you wanna break
it to pieces, it is completely fine by
me.
Okay. So let's get started with if you
go down a little bit, then in the
read me, we have there something about the
kill.
That should be the second one. Yep.
So let's just run that from the, REPL
that you checked out.
Oh, I've not cloned it yet.
Who's that in the chat that said I'm
finally breaking stuff?
Hey, LP. He isn't it?
Alright.
So
let's apply.
Oh, it doesn't exist. I'm just doing what
I do best.
A typo.
There we go.
I'm assuming this is going to be a
pod that eats up a whole bunch of
memory.
Indeed. And getting unclean. So this one is
Java then. Right?
It's gotta be. So what do you need
to see when when your pod is unclean?
What what do you you usually check?
I
wanna check the resource constraints to see what
the the memory limits are set at. And,
obviously, if I can get some information from
Prometheus,
I'd normally like to see it's a tumbling
value over the last thirty minutes to see
if this was, like, a blip or if
it was a gradual growth, something like that.
Yeah. That's that's makes sense.
Now
we're gonna try and, like,
listen to people like you and then gather
that information upfront and send it to you.
Yeah. Well, go over to Slack, see how
we did on this one.
Alright.
I've got too many tabs, I don't wanna
put anything. There we go.
Okay. So we got our high severity
pod umco,
namespace node name. Okay. So we got the
node allocated memory, that's useful right off the
bat.
The container name is memory eater. Nice.
And we can see the request and a
limit right in front of us.
So,
yeah. That's quite a good amount of information
upfront.
I'm assuming it's been on code because it's
at the hundred meg limit and then we've
got some links.
Are these oh, that's a binary.
So it's Oh, it's an SVG.
Yeah. But you can open up not the
PNG version. We're gonna knock out those SVG
those SVGs soon because that doesn't run well.
Oh, sweet. So we get that tumbling value.
So I can actually see that it's quite
a
quite a claim.
And the node looks okay. The memory chart
for your pod and for your node, and
then hopefully,
gives you a lot more context on your
your own kid's pod.
Yeah.
I see a line, a scary line. I
don't trust this workload anymore.
I guess Now
Sorry, Nico.
It's an example that's optimized for demos. But,
like, in a real life scenario, then you'd
see spikiness, and then you'd see also if
it's going up over time and then you
know there's a memory leak there as well.
Yeah. Like, you know, if this was a
real production application
and then something gets unkilled,
been able to see that memory claim because
you always wanna know whether this is just,
you know, it's just consistent growth. You know,
it's just it's just running over time and
maybe we just need to set we need
to restart that pod every six hours or
something, which is our hacky fix, but we've
all done it. Right? Because because we have
some memory leak, we've not debugged yet. Or
it could be that it's just absolute context
situation
where, oh, maybe we got a spike of
10,000 users in a fifteen minute window and
that caused our Redis cache to just completely
fill up and fall over. Like, you know,
not until you start to connect these dots
of all these disparate systems within your cluster
that you really understand what is actually happening
here. So
Exactly. Yeah. So what we're trying to do
is make it easier to connect those dots
where we can't connect them automatically.
And where you have dots that you know
makes sense to connect and to also make
it easy for you to connect them and
even easy for you to say, okay. Well,
next time this happens,
like, okay. Go and restart this pod after
five hours before it reaches the six hour
mark when it's at 80% mark.
So these attachments
on like, I I I don't know how
this is configured, this trigger and the actions
and stuff like that. But can I add
new PNGs with different queries against the Prometheus?
Is that something that's an option?
Yeah. Exactly.
You can indeed. Do you wanna go over
to the GitHub, the main GitHub for Robusta
and check out the helm values file?
Yes.
There we go.
Yeah. And now over here, that's just going
to the Helm folder and then right into
the default values file.
And look in here for.
This one?
Yep. And that's just how it's configured.
Okay. What are these special terms in the
Robusta?
Yeah. So we have here three different enrichers.
One of them is pulling in that data
that you saw,
the pod and killer enricher.
The other one is a little bit more
generic, but it's it's creating that graph, but
it's optimized specifically for the scenario so it
knows to add on the limits.
And then the third one is totally generic.
It just says take this pod, go with
whatever node it's running on, and grab their
graph of the memory from that node that
this pod is running on.
Nice. Okay.
Cool. So I can add more of these.
What kind of enrichers are available then to
people? Is there a list somewhere?
Yep. Yep. Yeah. But this documentation,
and this is the main area, by the
way, like, that we're really gonna focus on
in 2023 and making this way easier to
navigate
and way easier to use. So this is
gonna be a big focus of ours.
If you look on the left hand side
of the page,
then you can find there,
on the left hand side of the page
in the menu, there's something there that says
actions.
Got it.
And we have here all these different actions.
Nice. And no, it's bash enricher.
I could have some fun with that one.
Yeah. I'm assuming I could just write a
bash script and lane and the yaml and
then does this run it or
Yeah. Click on the example config.
See that that's awesome. Right? Like,
I used to be an SRE and I
used to give talks about how terrible I
was at being an SRE. Right? Because I
used to get alerts at 03:00 in the
morning and we had a a six month
old at this time. Right? So my wife
was already hating the fact that she'd only
been asleep for ten minutes and my alerts
gone off crazy.
So I would always just, like, grab my
laptop and it would be like a disk
alert and say, oh, you're at 96% or
whatever.
And I would just go on and delete
the log directory on a Linux machine. Like,
I because I just wanted to go back
to sleep, but I never actually spent enough
time to work it out and do it
properly. But if we had the ability if
I had the ability to just have a
bash command and, like, run, like, a d
u dash h against the directories, do a
depth on it, and kind of analyze where
the actual consumption is coming from and identify
the process. Like, I could chain a bunch
of these bash commands together and I would
have all the information I need to actually
fix it once and for all instead of
just taking the lazy approach.
So but, yeah, that's really cool. I'm glad
that's the first one I've seen.
Yeah. Exactly. And I see there's a comment
here in the chat.
Wind is asking, does it create just Prometheus
rules
objects in the cluster?
So,
yeah, the answer is, yes and no.
We do create Prometheus rules in the cluster
if you take the default alerts that we
provide.
And if you already have other manager rather
than you already have Prometheus,
then you can disable that. You can just
say use my existing Don't create any rules
for me. And then the second part of
this is we're not just creating those Prometheus
rules. We're taking those, like, the Prometheus Prometheus
alerts, and then we're tying them together
to, like, the different context gathering in the
runbook automation. So, essentially, we're doing two things.
We're installing default alerts if you don't already
have them, and that does create Prometheus rules.
And then the second thing that we always
do is we take those alerts, and we
now pull in the right context.
And for that, you you can't do that
with Prometheus alone because it's not just based
on time series databases.
It's, like, not just based on looking at
time series. It's saying, okay. Here's an alert.
Look at the labels here. Has this label
saying that's running on this node. Go run
this batch command on that node and so
on.
Nice.
So a big part of what we do
is not only
building the platform that enables to do that,
but we also
want to collect the community knowledge. So if
you have
some insights about some specific alert and you
know
as someone who who is specialized in that,
what exactly you need to do, you can
actually contribute
your own playbook and even your own alert,
and then
everyone else can enjoy the the benefit of
It's about taking
it's like you said at the beginning. Right?
Like, you have all the data there, and
you're trying to find the signal and the
noise.
So what we're saying is, okay. If you're
running on Kubernetes, we all actually have this
very similar alerts anyway because we're all
on these different scenarios.
I mean,
there's, like, known issues with the nodes,
then we're all dirthing on the same common
scenarios. So why not also share the investigation
for that? Why not share that as community
knowledge?
Nice.
Alright. Let me scan what other ones we
have here. Uh-oh.
The node graph nurture.
Everybody loves a good graph. Right?
Hard bash. Does this run up
execute a command and save the pod?
It does. So you would put that if
you have an alert that fires on a
specific pod,
then that would execute on the pod with
either it fires. Yeah. And send you the
results to Slack or whatever you define.
Okay.
Alright. There's quite a lot of choice here.
I'm not gonna scroll through
all of these, but there's definitely a lot
of flexibility
in the enrichers that we can add. And
that was just was that just the event
ones? There's, like, remediation
stuff.
And Yep. So when this sort of fires,
we're going to be the
hyphen troubleshooting. When this happen.
Alright. There's loads.
Alright. So we'll take a look at another
example?
Yep. Let's go back
for a second to the demo repository.
I think we'll look at one last example
that will be good to generate the concept.
And I wanna take here
may go down a little bit.
Just a little bit more. Yeah. I wanna
take care of an example with pending pods.
So skip the next one. The CPU throttling,
we can skip.
Just like the,
you know, pull pull in the relevant data.
And, yeah, let's take care of the pending
pods one.
I'll clean up after myself.
I think it's gone.
Now the pending pods is an interesting one
because
what we're trying to do is we're trying
to give everyone the best out of the
box experience,
and that means it means we have to
make decisions about what we are there on.
Right? Because let's say you have
a normal healthy cluster and you have an
autoscaler defined.
A pending pod isn't necessarily a big deal
because the autoscaler will fix it. You spin
up a new node. It takes a few
minutes.
And then once you spin up that new
node, now everything is fine. Right?
Like, the pod won't be pending anymore. So
for pending pods,
you actually don't wanna alert on that right
away. So by default of the box, we
don't send you an alert right when the
pending pod happens.
We wait fifteen minutes,
and then we send it if that hasn't
been resolved, and then we give the autoscaler
a chance to do that.
But
if you have pods that are pending, you
still wanna get some form of visibility into
that. So that also ties into what we're
doing in the SaaS platform, where here's a
scenario where we don't wanna alert you on
it. But if you're going and you're checking,
you're saying, okay. Well, I just deployed what's
going on. We still wanna give you that
visibility even before it becomes an issue.
Okay. Does that mean we're sitting here for
fifteen minutes? Because No. I was thinking we
could open up I I was thinking we
could open up this SaaS platform, and then
we'll also tie that into some other stuff
that
we didn't show off in that we that's
in the open source as well that we
didn't show off.
Alright.
How does one get to the Robusta SaaS
platform? I guess the login button. Yep.
Now because I just typed in my email
address and I don't have an account, if
I click Google off, is it gonna work?
Yep.
I think I will need to
move this to the right profile, though.
You're gonna hack me?
I don't really get access to do anything
meaningful.
No. It's just It's just OAuth. Yeah.
Alright. It was just a fairly random
sub domain string on that super base thing
there. Yeah. Yeah.
Alright.
So
what do we have here? I don't think
I've seen the SaaS platform
before. Did we look at this last time?
I don't know. And if we did, it
looked totally different.
Alright. Why don't you give us the guided
tour?
Okay. So let's click let's
say on
let's
take
what's a good place to take?
Let's just take one any one of these.
Take GKE metrics that you check.
Yep. And now
you can see here there was a transient
issue, but it fixed itself. There was some
issue with the mount that self resolved, so
that's just debug priority under the priority there.
We're saying this wasn't important. It happened. You
might wanna know about it, but it wasn't
important.
And now if you jump over to the
pad screen for a second,
then one thing that we can do is
we can let you pull in different data
here
from what's running in your cluster.
But for security reasons, we want you to
generate a token that's specific to your browser,
so to give it, like, access to do
that.
I think you need just a step three.
Yeah.
Yeah. I've already used my context. Right? So
I don't need to worry about that. I
can just do this.
Okay.
So what happened?
Let me check.
Okay. So we generated a token so that
Robusta will have access to pull in a
little bit of data, very limited data type
pulls from Robusta itself,
about what's going on in your cluster. And
that will then pull into the SaaS platform
some graphs, like, about different metrics, CPU usage,
and so on, and to get dogs.
Okay. So the Robusta that we installed to
the cluster, does that have any permissions to
the rest of stuff? Does it speak to
the SaaS platform? Are they completely independent? Like,
what's the relationship between those two components?
Yeah. So it depends on whether you enable
it or don't enable it. So if you
start off and you check off at the
beginning that you don't wanna enable the SaaS
platform,
then nothing gets sent.
And if you check off that you do
wanna enable the SaaS platform,
then we're sending just metadata there, like, dirt's
crashing pods, so data about what's happening,
and it's all with a push model.
Now when you go into the UI, though,
you might wanna see data there. Like, you
might wanna see data. Okay. Where is the
pod log right now? In order to enable
that, then you have to explicitly give permission
there.
Okay. And is this a short lived token,
or is this something I should be cleaning
up after a certain amount of time? Does
it have an expiration?
This is a token that you can remove
from the UI itself afterwards. It's not a
Kubernetes token or anything. So it doesn't have
any Kubernetes meaning.
It just has meaning in Robusta itself to
authorize your computer.
Okay. Got it. Cool.
So now we get some information
about the the pod itself. Right? So we
can see the
CPU and memory consumption,
and we can see that there's more than
one of them.
Mhmm. Yep. And if you wanted, then you
could pull in from here the logs, for
example. You can see different data.
And one thing that's cool about this is
we're doing this on all your different clusters.
So even if this was a microservice that
was running
on 300 different clusters, you would still get
a single pane of glass to see all
those different clusters in one single place.
Alright.
But let's go back to that transient issue
we were speaking about. We were saying, okay.
How sometimes this issue that occurs,
that's a transient issue. So just click here
on the timeline page on the left.
Am I on it? Oh, no. That's over.
That's fine. Okay. Yep.
And then you can see here
we can go in here, and we can
see some of these transient issues.
So
I'm gonna want you to can you go
first just zoom in a little bit with
your scroll bar on the right hand side
of this graph?
If you use your scroll bar on the
right hand on the graph itself, put your
mouse over the graph.
Yeah. And then you can zoom in.
Yeah. You can drag it as well.
Zoomed in a little bit too much.
Oh,
never trust me with a mouse. This is
what I'm learning today. Alright. Hold on. And
the resume and there we go. That's what
you wanted?
Yeah. So see that icon on the top
row?
Mhmm.
Yep. So if you click there, then that's
an example. Yeah. Just click on that. Oh,
I just wanna make sure I understand what
I'm seeing here. So this
these are the different types of things, events
within my Kubernetes cluster.
This is
a timeline of when these events happen. I
don't understand what the colors are yet, but
that's okay.
And this change one is not like the
others. Why
is that? Because this is a special event.
Is that got some significance?
This comes from the API server. So we're
tracking a list of all the different changes
that happen. What I would do is go
in and run KubeCatl edit on a deployment
or a pod or something in your cluster,
even that crash pods.
And we're using the UI here to show
this, but you could do this even without
the UI. Like, what we're doing here when
we're tracking all these changes, this is based
on KubeWatch.
And all the functionality here, it's important to
emphasize, it's also in the open source. So
the UI is just like a thin layer
on top.
You can change the,
like, the time range for one hour. It
will be, like yeah. Yeah. Up they'll be
above that.
I'm just gonna start playing with all the
sentence now.
Mhmm. Yep. Maybe hit the refresh button there.
Have I broke it?
That's I may not get the label, the
metadata change. Maybe that was just a silly
change.
I'll delete the pod.
No. I want do a change. The deletion
will definitely pick up on, but do a
change. Maybe go back to the change.
Yeah. Do edit pods or edit deployment. Do
you change the pod or the deployment? I
changed the labels
on the pod.
So try changing the deployment. We might
if the pod is part of its deployment,
we might only look at the deployment.
One moment.
So let's change the replicas. Right? This is
probably a change I'd wanna be able to
visualize.
Alright. And I'll give that one moment.
Well, what can you do about the demo
gods?
What
can you do?
Me.
Can you check what's in your Robusta on
your logs?
Yeah. Sure.
Do deployment slash Robusta around there.
Yeah.
Oh.
No. I think that's okay. Yeah. I don't
think it's that. It should appear in the
UI, I guess, in a few seconds. Go
back to the UI and see if it
appeared yet.
Right. So I'll I'll look into that a
little bit afterward. Let me go back, I
mean, go back to the home page over
here.
Yep. And you added a crash pod. Right?
Mhmm. Yeah.
I did. Yes.
So if you click here,
me
I'll have to take a look later on
and see what's going on there. Well, it's
noticed that it's not scaled up.
Yep. That is true. I'll
need to check and see what's going on
with the change over there. But let's go
back for a second now. Just go back
to the main app screen.
So just go on the left over to
the app screen. Yep.
Now remember we put here this example pod
that was gonna go into pending state? So
just open this up.
And if you go down here and you
look at the morning, then you can see
here, okay. It failed scheduling,
and we're pulling in here the reasons why
it failed scheduling.
So you can see here that it failed
to be scheduled because three nodes didn't match
the pods node selector.
Uh-huh.
And what we're doing here is we're pulling
in out the events
to show you the data on what's going
on. Even if this is a transient issue,
we're still showing you the data on why
this is happening.
Nice.
Quite an issue. Alright?
Thank you. I'm gonna have our also our
UI UX design
tomorrow, and then she'll go over the stuff
and then she'll pick pick out the things
where you didn't click on the things she
thought you would click on, and we'll do
improvements on that. So that's always useful.
Yeah. I think my Zoom is causing problems,
but yeah.
I like this kind of level of visibility
into everything. I like this timeline view.
I think that's very clever.
And then, yeah,
understanding why the pod isn't scheduling. Like,
is this something that you expect to, like,
hypothetical question here because I don't know if
it does this just now. I don't know
if it's going to do this in the
future, etcetera.
But I wonder
if a pod fails to schedule and it's
because of,
you know, the CPU of the memory request
can't be satisfied by a member in the
cluster, then we could probably expect that pending
status which kicks off the cluster autoscaler will
eventually
work.
But this one was an affinity selector,
like, does does Robusta know that there are
no nodes with those matching criteria?
And can it can can it handle that
differently? Is that what it's doing already?
Yeah. So we don't have that resolution yet
today, but what we've done is we've built
out, like, the thing which we can express
that resolution.
And a big part of what we're doing
in 2023
is to handle, like, increase our coverage on
each of those fine edge cases.
Yeah. Because, you know, I could be especially
with with node topologies and different architectures and
GPUs now, there's probably a lot of things
that you can just make assumptions about. Like
if there are no GPUs in the the
cluster, maybe there's never going to be any
GPUs in the cluster. And if there's no
nodes and EU East one, maybe it's because
we never deployed EU East 1. There's almost
just copy and pasted some crappy YAML from
the Internet into their cluster. Like, these are
probably things you could surface relatively quickly for
people, and it doesn't require
a lot of knowledge of their cluster. You
can make certain assumptions, I guess, based on
the the complete lack of
a certain criteria. Yeah. I think this is
a really interesting space where you can deliver
a lot of real value to people with
some very simple kind of checks like that.
That that's cool. I really like this.
Yeah. No. It's kinda like open sourcing the
operations. It's like taking how you work,
forcing,
like, the way that we actually think and
we handle this.
Right? Like, ultimately, this is just a rule
in the in the repository that's written in
YAML. And we're, like, taking the knowledge out
of your head for how you would handle
this error and now turning into codes.
It's almost like infrastructure as code said, okay.
You shouldn't set up servers ad hoc. And
what we're doing is we're doing incident response
as code and saying that you shouldn't respond
to incidents ad hoc either.
Okay.
Nice.
Alright. We still got a whole bunch of
tabs on the robust assess. Do you wanna
dive into any of them? I see we've
got jobs, notes, comparison, health, silences.
So everything here you would like to show
up?
Arik,
anything you wanna emphasize?
No.
We're constantly adding and adding.
So the help of new to just give
you, like, a one if you have a
lot of clusters to give you a single
overview of everything over there. The silences,
when there's a Prometheus alert, then we add
their silence button in Slack. So with one
click, you can silence alerts directly from Slack,
and then that shows up in the silences
screen.
So
tell me a couple more things then about
the the SaaS platform. For people that wanna
get started and start using it, is there
a free tier?
How do they get started? Is it as
simple as what we've shown today? Maybe you
can give them a little bit more detail.
Yeah. Sure. I mean, so very extensive free
tier.
Mean, we
currently have our free tier up to 50
nodes.
Mean, so that's 50. Five zero. Yeah.
You've seen them in shock.
I mean,
I just
yeah. It's it's it's not a lot of
nodes. You know, obviously, the clusters get much,
much bigger than this. But I think it's
it's rare or maybe it's just the people
that are calling me asking for help is
that their clusters are normally in that kind
of eight to 12, maybe 20 and absolute,
personally. That is a very generous three tier.
Yeah. We know that. Yep. We know. We're
not guaranteeing that we will forever have 50
nodes on there. Although if someone adds things
on in advance
and they're already on, like, Robusta, then we
do try and, like, at least be thoughtful.
Like, if people if we ever change the
tier, we will try and be thoughtful people
who are also there beforehand.
And is there a limit on how many
clusters of up to 50 nodes I can
have on my account?
No. We don't wanna force you in that
regards. You can deploy however you want. You
want, like, to split everything up into clusters.
That's fine. You want everything on one mega
cluster. That's your choice. That shouldn't affect like,
our software shouldn't affect how you choose to
deploy.
So I could have 10 clusters with 49
nodes each and that's still free tier, or
have I misunderstood? Is it 50 nodes total?
50 nodes total. Ah, okay. Yeah. Okay. That
makes a lot more sense. Alright.
Yeah. I just assumed I could have an
inform a clusters with 50 notes, but that
was just me. Mean, you could technically create
a different account for each one, like, you
probably we wouldn't go after you, but I
think the value add from what I'm seeing
so far is this multi cluster pane of
glass. Like, you know, this UI with apps
and timeline and jobs, we've got all the
debugging information there. We've got alerts.
Like, you know,
multi cluster is definitely a growing
popular way of running Kubernetes, lots of smaller
clusters. And that single pane of glass is
still a kind of missing piece of the
puzzle so far.
Especially as it comes to actually being able
to apply run books or logic or conditional
statements to those clusters rather than just have
a graph on Grafana that can filter by
the cluster.
Yeah. Exactly. I I think where you're going
with this, I like the direction, and I'm
very excited to see this.
So yeah. There's a question too, I think,
also about that you can also rather route
others with Grafana.
So the big part of what we're doing
here is to not just route the alerts
to the right destination,
but to pull in the right context.
Like, if I go back to that example
with the radioactive box that I started off
with, then, like, you wanna find out that
there's a radioactive box there, but you also
wanna find out what that box means and
to see the context there as fast as
possible. So our goal is to pull in
the right data and show you all the
right data at the right time, not just
to do the other routing, which you can
obviously do on your own as well.
Cool.
Alright. If anyone else has any more questions,
feel free to drop them into the comment
section, and we'll pass them on before we
finish for today.
Alright. So as far as
what we've looked at today,
we've got all these options for enrichers.
If I wanna start going rogue on this
and do my own thing,
what's the best place to
get examples?
In the docs. So if you go to
the docs, then we have examples there on
configuring the enrichers,
and we have examples on writing your own
enrichers too. So for example, you could do
an enricher that takes an alert, and,
it acts asks GPT
sorry, chat GPT
what you should do about that alert and
then sends it on Slack channel or to
Discord.
So you could do that, something like that
if you wanted. Have you already done that
demo?
I haven't. I wish I hadn't.
If someone does that demo, though, we will
send you swag to your house.
We will send you swag
and special swag. I will I will send
you a custom swag that no one else
in the world has ever gotten if you
ask
chat GPT.
I think that would be generally awesome. Like,
I think we've all seen enough of these
chat GPT things on Twitter now where people
are filling up with a bunch of context
and then ask a question based on that
new information. And you could totally do that
with Robusta. Like, here's the logs for my
application and here is the scheduling problems for
this pod.
Like, what is the remediation path here? Thanks.
And it would probably tell you, oh, you
need to go and spin up a note
of a GPU on it or you need
to tweak your requests and limits, etcetera. Like
We actually have an enrichment that
run the search on Stack Overflow. So this
will be an enhanced version of that. Do
you wanna try and configure one that runs
the search on Stack Overflow?
Does that work?
I I think so. I mean, let's let's
go let's go to actions.
Uh-huh.
And I'll just say in the meantime, I
think it's under event enrichment.
Either event enrichment or miscellaneous. Just look here
for Stack Overflow.
Yep. Stack Overflow and richer.
And in the meantime, I'm just gonna say
to Wind, excellent questions. So thank you very
much.
And, also, we're on Slack stuff, and we
have a community. So if you have any
questions, always reach out. Okay. Now take care
of the example config.
And yep. And so you're just gonna copy
this.
Copy the whole thing. Oh, the whole thing.
And now we're gonna add this to the
your home values. So you have to now
change the home values,
and you should have already have the generated
values.
And we just add on a new value
here called custom playbooks.
I think yep. C u s t o
m.
Yep. Playbooks.
Yep. And just pop this in here, but
just make that, like, a member of an
array. Custom playbooks is an array.
Yeah. Okay. And
then you have to indent all of this.
With that. Right? No. The triggers, yeah, should
be the triggers should be backspaced. No. The
triggers
Yeah.
Backspaced.
Two backspaces on that line and the line
after it. Yeah. On triggers and on.
Yeah.
That's it. And Oh, yeah. Actions and then
trigger. Alright. Okay. Gotcha. Gotcha.
See, YAML's hard.
Yeah. Yeah.
So just save that to the helm.
Upgrade.
Okay. In fact, I still have my helm
command here.
And I'll need to change this. Oh, no.
Don't do it again.
Home upgrade
slash slash install. Is that gonna be enough?
Yep. Perfect.
So now when we cause some sort of
failure scenario,
it looks up the
it does a search for Stack Overflow with
some of the information and then tries to
get me
a response?
Something like that. Yeah. We'll see it in
action.
I mean, I'm hoping you don't just copy
and paste the commands from Stack Overflow and
paste them into my cluster. Although that would
be fine. I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
do that. This is actually one of first
enrichers I wrote to kind of play around
with the concept myself
and mostly as a toy, like, not as
a real production use case, but it's interesting
to show the concept.
Well, let's go to
Robusta.
So where's the code for the enrichers?
So go into playbooks,
and then we have here there should be
one here called Stack Overflow.
Let's see. Maybe
so try
Search?
Yeah. Try doing a search on Stack Overflow.
Yep. There we go. There's integration.
So 9262.
Okay.
So I can add chat GPT
and 25 lines of code, hopefully.
Exactly. Yeah. Because I I actually have played
with the chat GPT API
and that is just a regular request you're
making to an endpoint with some context. I
mean, we could totally make that work. Not
that suggestion we try and do it right
now, but I think this demo needs to
exist
and has to exist soon.
So
If you do this, our our offer stands.
We will send you some incredible customized
one off swag that no one else in
the world has.
Consider it done. Only that. Well, the text
on the shirt, we will generate with ChatGPT.
I will ask chat GPT to give me
the appropriate
quote for the shirt to send you.
Alright.
I mean, we could just have chat GPT
take over the stream as well. I'm pretty
sure. Just write write a script to show
off Robusta demo and improving your previous monitoring
and alert.
Yep. We have deployed the Stack Overflow thing,
I think.
So
how how do we check?
We have a utility in the CLI that
generates a demo alert. So
you run Robusta
demo minus alert.
So it takes a random pod from the
cluster and create the and a major alert
on that.
And then within few minutes, you should be
able you should get a new message on
Slack.
That, I believe, arrived yeah. That arrived beforehand.
That's not from right now. So just give
it a moment. You have a manager's sinuses.
So it sorry. An manager wait period, so
it takes a moment.
Yeah. This one's from six minutes ago, so
we just need to be
be patient.
Yep.
Are you all the you're all the way
scrolled down there. Right? Yeah.
Okay. Cool. Cool. Cool.
Mhmm. Just a weird
Yeah. Yeah. So
while we're waiting, though, I'll say, okay. Here's
an alert. So see how how there's that
silence button at the top of the alert?
So I used to get a live alerts
in Slack, and then sometimes I wanna silence
them, but it was, like, annoying to do,
or I had multiple clusters that I'd have
to go and silence them on. So sometimes
I didn't really do what I should have,
and sometimes I didn't silence them, and I
would just get that same alert every six
hours.
So we've tried to make it really easy
to silence.
And even if you have, like, 10 different
clusters, each with their own Prometheus and alert
manager, then you can push out with one
click that silence to all the different clusters.
And we prefill all the boxes here. It's
really, like, trying to encourage you to silence
something if it's noisy.
You need to put Mhmm.
Oh, no. But if you silence this, we're
gonna silence the dirt that
you have to delete it. We're gonna silence
the dirt that we have to simulate.
The the same what? Yeah.
And I've heard from that
we will have a hundred at stars
at some point during this stream. A thousand?
Sorry. A thousand GitHub stars. At some point
during the stream, we're currently on 999.
So if you're the lucky person who gets
this thousand star,
then,
send it to us, and we will send
you a T shirt.
Oh, I've already started it. Correct.
Whoever gets the thousand star, just screenshot it
and post it on Twitter afterwards.
Tag me, tag, David, and we will send
you a T shirt.
Alright. Someone get out there. Win that T
shirt.
Let's
see.
We still don't have our Stack Overflow alert
just yet.
Okay. Let's check the dogs. And someone just
got a T shirt. I don't know who,
but someone just got the T shirt, so
congrats.
Hey.
Nice.
Okay. So we think there's no problem?
I don't know. Let's jump over. Let's check
the Robusta dogs.
From the runner?
Yep. Yep. Congratulations,
JS. We got that T shirt.
Alright. Well done.
Yeah. I don't see any issue here.
Maybe we just need to wait a couple
of more minutes until
alert manager will file it. There's default alert
manager silences.
Mhmm. So it's not silences. I'll wait periods.
So when you send in the dirt, depending
on your configuration, it actually takes some time
for the dirt to arrive.
Let
me see. I'm trying to think if there's
a different way we could simulate it faster.
Yeah. Maybe
we have an alert simulation playbook you can
take. That that's not the demo there it
does?
No. It creates an an alert on alert
manager. Oh, that's why we have to wait
the period. Mhmm. Okay. So can you send
him the command then for the we're gonna
send you a way that does it faster.
It's here. It's here. Woo hoo.
And now if you click the button,
the
search Stack Overflow for
So this also shows, like, how playbooks can
be interactive.
Here's an example of a playbook that's taking
an action. You can also automatically remediate stuff
when you click that button. You can do
it different ways.
I think it will be really good to
have chat GPT.
Yes. Whoever flat GPT is getting the prize.
I'm telling you.
Hey. This stream's done. I've got some code
to write.
I'll point everyone in the right direction. Okay.
So go over to the Robusta docs,
and there's a tutorial there on the left
that says custom automation.
And that tutorial shows you how to write
your own playbook and to load into Robusta.
And the source code, of course, So the
source code for this, can you drop in
the source code for the Stack Overflow one
so people know what they can go and
copy?
Alright. We'll drop that into the chat.
Which one? The Stack Overflow one. Yeah.
I think David's gonna do it anyway. Okay.
David might email someone else.
So it's just some Python code. So nice
and easy for people to work with web
APIs and pass in the data. I'm assuming
that's event event,
which I'm loving the name of and hating
it every much the same at the same
time.
Yep. Does does this
get event event get event.
Does that have all of that enrichment that
was previously done? Like what what do they
have access to? I know we see we've
got type, we've got reason, but does it
have the logs? Does it have
the request and memory limits from the other
enricher? Like, what what do we have access
to within
this? So each enricher is independent and each
enricher access, it depends on the event there.
And I know event event has a really
awkward name.
But what event event represents,
like okay. What you would normally see there
isn't event event. What you would normally see
is pod event or deployment events.
And in this case, it's
really a an event that happened on a
Kubernetes event. You were listening to kubectl get
effect. So I know that's a super awkward
name and, like, I'm sorry about that.
But
what you would so what you would have
access to on the event object depends
on, like,
what it is. So if you're looking at
pod event, you can access the logs. If
you're looking at Prometheus event, then you can
access the pod that's associated with that. You
can access the Prometheus labels, the alert name,
and all the different stuff. And you have
all the complete, of course. So you'll just
be able to see there what's available.
Nice.
Alright. I'll be playing with that later on.
So
I think we're shown a lot here. We
deployed Robusta.
We've used the SaaS platform. We've poked around
our cluster. We caused a couple of failure
scenarios.
We've seen the messages come into Slack. We've
seen that those are interactive. We've got the
Slack overflow one. We've got the silences.
There's there's a lot of value from people
deploying Robusta to the cluster. So maybe if
you're happy to, you could tell us, like,
what are you working on? What's coming next?
How are you going to take Robusta to
the next level?
Oh, so let me open up my slides
and I'm gonna show exactly that.
So is there anything else you want to
show on on my side before we do
that? Like, I didn't mean to
No.
No. I think that's
Alright. Your slides are now live. Take it
away.
Okay. So I'll I'll speak briefly on what
we've done since we were last here. So
what we did is a live coverage. So,
like, that's a lots of stuff to cover
all these different things,
all these different scenarios and add these playbooks
for them. And the second thing we did
was to add in live destinations.
So last time we were here, you could
send stuff to, think, just Slack, and we
added on MS Teams and Discord and PagerDuty
and Cisco Webex and Opsgenie and all these
other destinations.
So those were the two main things that
we worked on here
as well as improvements to the SaaS platform,
but those were the main improvements in the
open source since we were last on the
stream.
And what we're gonna be working on in
the next year is more coverage. So it's
got different types of stuff,
major improvements to developer experience to to make
it even easier to update the playbook definitions.
And I edited my slides while you were
talking. So I think we're gonna get top
GPT
from David Flanagan.
They
from our favorite Rawkode,
and there'll be some more surprises coming, more
stuff that we're going to work on. We're
very driven by feedback we get. So, like,
it's the old saying goes, like, send us
all your weary and tired alerts. So, like,
tell us what's going on in your clusters.
Tell us what you want automated or why.
Tell us what issues you saw that happened
in your cluster that were annoying to investigate,
and those will go into their own map.
Tell us if you wanna send alerts to
different destinations that we don't support today. That's
why we support now
PagerDuty and AppsGenie, and, of course, we got
a lot of contributions there from the community
who have open PR requests as well. So
I think that's everything.
There's some more stuff I could talk about,
but I think those are the main things.
Awesome. Thank you. Alright. Let me pop this
back over to here.
So thank you for sorry. Were you are
you not done? Oh, hey to JS. I
I want I need to get your address
and stuff, so message me afterwards on Twitter.
And it's already late here, so I'll probably
reply to you tomorrow. But message me on
Twitter, and then I'll put you in touch
with Mayan from our team, and you'll get
some swag.
Yeah. Definitely drop him a DM, get that
swag.
Alright.
Well, thank you both for joining me today.
It's been fun taking a look at Robusta
again. It's always great to see where these
projects are going and the speed and the
velocity that these projects are kind of evolving
at. So it's just nice to to see
that you're making people's Kubernetes lives a little
bit easier.
So thank you again for taking the time.
Any last words before we finish up for
today?
Oh, there is a fun remark.
I I think,
but I think last time that Arik and
I were here, then there was someone in
the chat
who
we noticed and who was creating excellent content
on Twitter and who we subsequently added to
our team,
So
I think
I
think that's, like, a good closing the circle.
Think Pohang was here as part of the
community last time, and now he's also here
as part of the team.
Maybe next time also on the screen with
us. So,
I
guess
it's good to say, like, we're doing our
best to really build that open source community.
We are always hiring as well. So if
this sort of thing interests you, then please
reach out. We're hiring for front end positions.
We're hiring for a lot of different stuff.
So
my DMs are open.
Yeah. JS, just include your CV or your
resume when you're requesting your swag T shirt.
You never know.
Yes. Yes. Yes, please.
And has been doing excellent work on the
Robusta team. We also have the widest Kubernetes
thing now that we're doing together.
So
sometimes interesting, some stuff comes out with these
streams.
Well, yeah, it's it's nice that we get
the opportunity to share knowledge with each other
and with others. And then for the people
that, you know, wanna get more involved, there's
always opportunities. You know, open source is one
of the most welcoming places to get involved
and start contributing. It doesn't take any prerequisites.
And especially, I've gotta say the Kubernetes is
a cloud native ecosystem with some of the
most welcoming communities I've ever had the honor
of kind of participating in. So
Yeah. It's like, you know that old joke
down the Internet, no one knows you're a
dog?
No. I don't know that joke. I
think it's a famous New Yorker I
think it's a famous New Yorker comic strip,
but
it's so true, especially with open source. Like,
it doesn't matter who you are or where
you are, even what age you are. I
first got involved in open source when I
was 14 years old, and I was like
an old kid who didn't go outside enough.
And
then next thing I knew it, was, like,
flying me out to different hackathons and conferences.
And it's really one of the incredible things
about open source, the ability to really connect
people and to, like, be judged based on
the merit of your codes, not on your
background, not on what country you live in.
Like, none of it even matters with open
source. They're all just melts away. So
thank you, David, for, like, helping also to
organize this event and this stream. And think
at least one person, like, is who is
in the community, we became closer to also
due to a stream like this. So thank
you very much. Yeah. Thank you.
Awesome. Alright. Well, thank you both again for
your time. It's been a pleasure. I'm sure
we'll speak again soon. And until next time,
we'll be back. Have a great day, everyone.
Yeah.